well
[Music]
how are you greetings from cristian cásseres
with your brief news now in
spanish thanks for joining us
we started with a fire that was
reported this morning and that ended
the lives of two people this happened
near paseo verde and cerros parkway
gender firefighters were told
two women are dead following the cause
of this crash however this case
remains under
investigation southwest valley
las vegas metropolitan police continue to
investigate a murder this happened
near jones and robben two detectives
say the  suspect shot
another person who was in his vehicle
parked at a gas station the shooting
continued inside the store there were no
injuries inside the business however
the driver died investigators are
still on the trail of the shooter
and after the members of the
board of directors  17 will meet today
a week after firing the
superintendent, Dr.  jesús jara
educational leaders began
the search for doctor jara's replacement they will
also discuss how they will move
forward in terms of education and we
continue to see blue and
sunny skies for today we will
have pleasant temperatures for the
rest of the week we will reach 80
degrees for  This afternoon
some winds are expected for the weekend
but it will be there this won't really make a
difference as temperatures
will be in the high 70s and we keep
reminding you of the time change don't
forget to set your watch this
weekend I'm cristian cásseres with your
brief  news now in spanish
good day
[Music]